AGAINST DALLAS.
>> HERE WE GO.
PETER McNABBENN.
GOT AWAY.
UP TOP, GIRARD SPINS NEAR SIDE.
TOEWS WILL RACE THERE.TATE IT BE
WAS ABSOLUTELY LOVING THE WAY
THAT HISE THEMSELVES A
CHANGE.
>> YEAH.
NOBODY AT FAULT. AND
YLER TAMPA.
YOU WON'T PLAY A BETTERTARS.
DOWN THE AGAIN, SCORE.
PERFECT PUCK MOVEMENT BY THE
DALLAS STARS STARS AND JOE
PAVE OUT, BEEN
ABLE  PLAY
LIVE.
>> WE TALK ABOUT TION
IN TERMS OF POINTS PER GAME.
STRAIGHT UP TOP.
PAST OF
GLOVES OF PAVEL LINE IN
THE 3-1 WIN FOR DALLAS EARLIER
THIS
HOLE OF OETTINGER AND THE.
HE COMES OUT FOR THE PRACTICE
YESTERDAY AND HE HAD SPECIFIC
INTERCEPTED BY TOEWS.
HE GOT KNOCKED FRANCOUZ.
WE'LL GET A LOOK ATAT
THE GAME AS HE WORKED IT RIGHT
INTO THE CREASE AND WAS ABLE TO.
>> REFEREE: COLORADO IS
CHALLENGING FOR
AROUND IN THERE.
NO QUESTION.ION ROOM INTORONTO .
LET'S SEE WHAT TH HAS. TOEWS.
DEVON TOEWS, SITTING ON NINE
GOALS THIS SEASON.
PLAY.
OWN END.
LANDESKOG TIPS IT AHEAD.
MacKINNON IS FLYING UP.
FRANCOUZ WAS MAKING A MOVE TO
THE BENCH.
THERE GOES PAVEL FR LEFT. STARS.
IT'S A 4-1
OPPORTUNISTIC DALLAS SQUAD
TONIGHT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER,